They, it's hard to swim with somebody,
you know that as well as anybody.
You saved somebody.
Yeah, I was in Costa Rica and uh,
we were down at this g this water,
it was the biggest
waterfall I've ever seen.
It was like hundreds of feet high
and it landed in this lagoon,
this round lagoon. And the water,
they told you don't go near the water.
And so there's these Japanese
girls sitting on the edge.
They got their feet in and then one of
them like jumps in and the water fucking
sucks her down immediately.
And I dove owl, I have,
I have a lifeguarding to Greg
from when I was stoned and 16.
And so I dove into the water and I grabbed
her and luckily I was checking them
out because they were these
beautiful Japanese. So I
had my eyes on them. And uh,
so I dive in and I grabbed, I grabbed
her and I pulled it to the surface.
I do the cross arm carry and
I've pulled out, I pull her out.
And you know what she did just turned,
turned to her friends.
They all like console there. Nobody said
thank you. I fucking saved her life.
So anyway. Wow. So there was these kids
and a three. You are jumping these lady.
How rude. How bad? A little
[inaudible] Japanese,
Japanese. I think she was Japanese. No,
no, they were Japanese. Japanese, yeah.
She probably thought you were a lifeguard.
Yeah.
Probably thought that's what
happened. Yeah. And then I,
and then I left and I'm with my family
and uh, they didn't see it happen,
so I was so fucking bummed.
Then we get to the parking lot and uh,
there's this busload of kids from some
school and they had seen the whole thing
and they started chanting hero to me.
Oh,
what do you fucking see
what's happening right now?
That's gotta be a great feeling. Even if
they didn't say thank you, you saved him.
Well, I, it's what I do. It's my job
superhero. You ever save anybody's life?
No, I don't think so. Not, not directly.
Maybe you did this podcast.
Probably did.
I bet there's people that
have been suicidal that
heard this and the cheer them
up. I bet it ruined a few
people too. Let's be honest.
I do. Don't listen to me. I'm a fucking
idiot. What are you listening to me?
Because if people say I changed
their life, I was like, okay,
if I accept it on the positive, then I
have to accept it on the negative too.
That's right. No, no. You did
it. You did the whole thing.
You might've heard I said some
shit that you you enjoyed.
I'm very happy for that and I talked to
some people that brought you some great
information. I'm very happy for that
too. We're all in this together.
I'm on saving anybody. Yeah, you save
yourself. Don't listen to me. Yeah,
call a hotline. Don't listen to me.
Don't take yoga. Don't even do it.
Don't take it. Don't want
us to me. I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
Don't pick up archery.
What the fuck do you want to do?
You want to shoot arrows at things? Fuck
out your carbs. Eat some fucking carbs.
Don't do Jujitsu. You're going to
get hurt. You want to get hurt.
You're a 40 year old man. We try to choke
people for stop it. Don't listen to me.
Don't eat elk. Go get a burger, but
we had an actual American hamburger.
Don't eat mushrooms. Get outta here. Going
to close your mind off. Break your head.
They're going to break your head.
What have you go crazy like that guy from
pink Floyd? Huh? What if you go crazy?
What if you never come back.